the injuries suffered by this man
crushed both the side and the front of
the head inwards causing a number of
fractures that radiated through how the
skull it also the blow on the side of
the head actually pushed the maxilla
that the lower part of the face sideways
I mean doing so it broke his neck so I
am sure the second blow killed him so
not a rock today is a barren area of
semi-desert and yet 10,000 years ago it
was the edge of a lagoon full of animals
which obviously also attracted
hunter-gatherers so when we came to work
in this part of of Kenya we were and we
still are looking for much older fossils
so I never expected to find the remains
of a massacre or the earliest massacre
recorded in history at the site of nifer
oak we found a total of 27 individuals
but most of these were fragmentary there
were 12 skeletons that were still
articulated in the ground some better
preserved than others and of those 10
had evidence of having died violently so
among these four have injuries that are
consistent with projectiles presumably
bows and arrows another four skeletons
have blows to the head and these would
have been done with a blunt instrument a
weapon like a club and then there are
some individuals that show fractures to
the knees to the hands to the ribs or
consistent with a pattern of conflict
wounds among the most unusual finds one
was this young lady who was found
sitting and she had her hands crossed in
a very peculiar position and they may
suggest that she was bound at the time
of death
and we found in her belly the remains of
a fetus that was near-term we also have
the remains of six very young children
under the age of six and these were
found next to the women my
interpretation is that this was a small
community a foraging party and that they
were surprised by an attack and they
died
some of them directly perhaps into the
shallow waters and they were covered by
water and cells and the bodies preserved
these people were massacred and my guess
is that there was nobody left around to
bury them so they lay where they fell
you